[Music]
Lewis Roberts 38 firefighter in central
London volunteer with the lifeboats and
I also trained in MMA in Felton they
enjoy the adrenaline I enjoy the moment
when you in an uncontrolled environment
but you're calm and centered within that
environment if I find something that's
out of my comfort zone I go and do it I
go and bring it into my comfort zone
attempt as a wizard stations in the RLI
it's not just an empty river its tidal
right sides high banks boats
you've got things at the bottom of the
river that shouldn't be there and if
you're the best swimmer you go into cold
water very quickly you'd lose your
ability to swim and you'll just drowned
little while ago a young chap swims
across the river makes it swims back
makes it everyone's happy everyone's
laughing joking it then does it again
and this time it doesn't make it you've
got to see the lifeboat going up
searching the police boat searching his
friends and family on the bank panicking
and unfortunately this young lad didn't
survive
honey been bit more aware of how
dangerous the river HB is you may not
have gone in you do realize your own
mortality when you're older doesn't stop
me from doing the things I enjoy you
know I just take that into consideration
there's a lot of things that we get
called to that it's just about awareness
live your life but just be mindful of
the potential hazards and things you
choose to do
[Music]